il était une fois des gens heureux
c'est très embêtant plus silencieux
c'est sans doute son plus grand succès
celui qui a marqué une génération
la chanson thème du film les plouffe
écrite par stéphane venne
[Musique]
elle a eu juste un jour à peine pour la
pente
et pourtant en arrivant un studio
la magie a opéré
et elle est devenue ce qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui
né en 1949 à donnacona dans une famille
passionnée de musique
nicole martel entame sa carrière à l'âge
de 14 ans
mais ses premiers véritables succès
remonte aux années 70
son charme son souffle mais surtout sa
voix suave et à la distingue et la
rendent très populaire son héritage
c'est pas d'avoir de la voix c'est de
savoir s'en servir
là c'est la cata reprenait la chanson
paix revienne dans l'amour l'a même
comparé dans les médias et pyatt
c'était une voix extraordinaire et on
savait bien commun
tous les jours elle a aussi été la muse
du parolier pierre létourneau
c'était ma plus grande amie de femmes de
toute ma vie
une très grande confiance en elle et
quand elle montait sur scène
attention en plus de sa carrière
prolifique de chanteuse ella et et
réalisatrice et productrice avec son
conjoint
lee abbott c'est lui qui a annoncé la
tragique nouvelle sur sa page facebook
la célèbre chanteuse a été emporté par
une maladie fulgurante il y as presque
mois à sa demande il a attendu avant de
rendre sa mort public
c'est une femme qui va marquer beaucoup
et ce que je ne comprends pas c'est que
je patinais ou cora pendant un mois même
qui était malade ça m'a beaucoup touché
parce que c'est une femme qui était qui
était vrai qui donnait d'ailleurs
absolument extraordinaire
[Musique]
une façon de partir tout en retenue à
son image et à l'image de son oeuvre
phare issigeac audrey charbonneau raid
au canada mon frère
[Musique]
à